this is the politician Sakia stammer
he's not just any politician he's the
leader of the labor party and he wants
to become the next prime minister good
morning I'm very good and he's come to
the FYI Studio at Sky headquarters
Johnson yeah
so who is Kia stammer and why should we
listen to what he has to say I do think
it's time that um the court system
became much more of a place where the
ordinary person feels they can go well
he used to be a lawyer in fact he became
circus Dharma when he was awarded a
Knighthood for services to the criminal
justice system
right
fantastic just five years after becoming
a politician he was elected by the
political party labor to be their leader
now that's a big deal since 1922 we've
either had a conservative or labor party
prime minister
for over a hundred years these parties
have been the two main players when it
comes to winning elections
[Music]
for the last 13 years the conservatives
have been in power Zaki estarma says
it's time for a change
but how different would it be if he were
in charge
[Music]
hey one FYI we feel people our age you
get to see on things that affects us
even if we don't get a vote and so we
asked Mr stormwater to Common FYI and
take questions from you and us and he
said yes
action Mr stormard thank you so so much
for joining us today thank you for
having me it's fantastic to be here I've
seen some of the other interviews you've
done so it's fantastic work and you've
won a bafta I think yes so you must be
buzzed
of the opposition so briefly briefly
what do you actually do
position uh the political party that
didn't win the election and therefore
are not running the government so we've
got really two main jobs the first is to
oppose the government everything they
put forward we test it we argue about it
make sure they're doing the right thing
and if they're not doing the right thing
we point it out I will keep fighting
until we get it
Mr Speaker the prime minister is biting
his tongue but the other thing we do is
to prepare for the next election
in the hope that we will win that
election and therefore not be the leader
of the opposition but be the Prime
Minister
um in government you haven't been the
government in 13 years I mean that's
nearly my interest don't rub it in this
is getting tough entire life well in the
hope of getting elected you've pledged
that you will deliver a better economy
National Health Service tackle crime for
climate crisis and deliver a better
education for all of us but if you
Google party pledges loads of leaders
have promised that time and time again
so why do you think we should trust you
and believe you're actually going to do
all of that well I think it's really
important that we've only said five
things so a lot of people who want to be
in government say oh we do everything
you want you know you just name it we'll
do it we've said no we're going to be
really really focused on the things
you've identified and climate change is
a really big one of those obviously the
test the end of whether people trust us
is when we get to that general election
so viewers and members from our FYI news
clubs at schools have been sending in
their questions yes right okay so that's
why we see them
here's Halima from Glasgow
hi I'm Halima and I'm from Glasgow I
think that everyone should have the
right to strike especially in the midst
of a cost of living crisis but do you
think it's fair that people we rely on
can go on strike like teachers doctors
nurses and ambulance workers
I do I think it's really important that
everyone has the right to go on strike
because if you don't have the right to
go on strike you don't really have the
ability to improve your pay and your
conditions and your circumstances at
work even if at
Emergency Services no nurse really wants
to go on strike but they feel very
strongly at the moment that they haven't
been paid properly have been you know
respected properly and they're at the
end of their tether
um I think the way to resolve it is for
the government to get in the room and
sort it out with them okay what do you
think what do you think about people
going on strike are your schools
affected well obviously the school
children are like happy yay no school
but that was the General theme in our
house but you know with the cost of
living they're going to get paid more
and then if the cost of living goes up
they're going to have to keep getting
paid this is such a really important
Point that's why
the first of the things you said to me
that we're going to do in government is
to grow the economy because even if
people have paid a bit more this year if
the economy isn't getting better and it
hasn't been getting better for you know
over 10 years now then we're going to be
back in the same position in a year's
time
hi my name is Olivia and I'm from
Maryland
Minister would you make all schools
green and talk about solar panels
yeah so she's asking if you'd put solar
panels on all schools across the UK yeah
I'm a big believer in solar panels on
schools in the primary school where my
children went they had a big project to
get the solar panels on schools but I
think we need to do much more than that
because I think the climate crisis is
the biggest challenge that we all face
it's going to be huge for you you know
because it's your future we're talking
about here and therefore we need a wind
turbines off in the sea on land we need
to make sure that we're not relying on
oil and gas in the way we have done for
a very long time so would you
age re vote from 8 18 to 16 letting
younger people get a chance to say on
things like climate change yes I've long
believed that we should have votes for
16 year olds and 17 year olds because
you can leave school and go to work then
what do you think yeah I think we should
be able to vote because we're the future
and we should be able to have a say on
what goes on around us and you know how
we want the world to be for generations
to come yeah I think that a lot of
younger people I mean even in my year A
lot of people are really interested in
politics already so it's like waiting
for the chance to vote like waiting for
the chance to yeah that's really good to
hear so our next question is from an FYI
News Club member in Northern Ireland
hello my name is Mimi and I come from a
family that is really struggling with
the rising costs of things I live in a
single parent household and we are only
ever one unexpected fellow way of not
being able to eat or stay warm Mr
Stormer politicians like you talk a lot
about how to help families like mine but
what experience of poverty do you
actually have
that's a really good question and I
don't know whether you know much about
me and how I grew up but I'll be very
quick my dad was a tool maker so he
worked in a factory and my mum was a
nurse but she was also sadly very ill
and so she couldn't work for very long
so actually we didn't have a lot of
money coming in and when we had a cost
of living crisis when I was about your
age we couldn't pay the bills that
question I think reflects what a lot of
families are feeling across the country
really really anxious about paying their
bills I think part of the job of
politicians is to want to understand
that and if you have experienced it I
think you can understand it better
preschool meals for all pupils would
help but that just isn't the case it
depends on where you live and that
really isn't there the labor party
leader before you demanded free School
meals for all do you at the we're we're
looking at this but we are careful and
making sure that whatever we say going
into the next election which will
probably be next year I don't know for
sure or is fully costed so everything
that we are putting forward we say
should be fully costed one of our
policies is a breakfast club at schools
for all schools breakfast clubs it just
seems like you're willing to pay for the
cheapest option like the cheapest meal
of the day well it doesn't have to be
like that um they're different in
different schools but it should be
um good food but also support for
children going into Breakfast Club but
also really importantly for parents to
be able to go to work
our next question is about a
long-running issue for many years
thousands of people from countries
affected by poverty have been trying to
get into the UK from the French Coast
they pay criminal gangs to help them
across the English tunnel in small boats
the Prime Minister Richie sunak has just
announced plans to arrest and Deport
anyone caught trying to get into the UK
illegally like this the issue is amongst
those using small boats are genuine
refugees and Asylum Seekers fleeing war
and violence
Refugee living in the UK my family had
to live around for our own safety we end
up in Calais in France and we had no
choice but to cross the English Channel
in a Dengue towards England like so many
families before us
Mr Stone the government says that they
want to work with the French authorities
to stop people reaching the UK on a boat
like my family did but what about
working with a friend start providing
Seafood to the UK for genuine refugees
like me
would you do that
so this is a really good question from
Alvin as you will know in this country
we've always been very welcoming of
refugees for many many years
um with different conflicts and things
going on in the world and we should have
safe passages in answer the question and
for people to get here going across the
channel in a boat is not a safe route
yes and behind that there are criminal
gangs that are running those routes and
so they are making money out of the
misery of people who are in a desperate
desperate situation so we need safe
route so that we don't have
um unsafe routes like the channel
Crossings and we don't allow those gangs
to exploit people and put them in that
awfully dangerous situation
hi my name's Crystal and I have to take
care of my parents or my sister
mum and dad are poorly and can't work
money is tight right now
my sister has ADHD and autism meaning
that she suffers from outbursts when she
gets frustrated I love Karen for my
family but it's hard when you have
school this means that I can't always
hang out with my friends
there are thousands of children like me
who care for their parents because there
aren't enough professional adult carers
what would you do about it
firstly we should just say Crystal's
amazing isn't she yes I mean to be to do
that at her age
is just incredible uh really really
incredible she shouldn't be put in that
position and that question is obviously
well what are you going to do to make
sure there are professionals there I
know a bit about this because my
sister's actually a care worker I think
that one of the reasons we don't have
enough professionals is that the pay and
conditions for care workers
professionals is so bad that many people
will come in do it for a while and then
leave again it's one of the biggest
problems so we've got to have better pay
better conditions and that should be
across the whole of the country well our
next question is from somebody who you
might recognize
hi I am Eva lovely I am a comedian and I
got the different finals Talent
I have a disability called Sarah
performs it which means I have wobbly
legs and wobbly arms and my speech is a
lot slower
sometimes it can make life really hard
my question for Kia stammer is what
would a labor government do to educate
young people on how to treat people with
disabilities
my answer to that would be to make sure
that we integrate children with
disabilities into our schools all the
time I've seen this done in some primary
schools and it was fantastic because you
had young people at primary school age
growing up in the same school
environment with people with quite
severe disabilities and understanding
being friends helping them and it was an
incredible experience and I think that
is so much better than sort of trying to
teach people in a classroom about
disabilities so before you go we have a
burning question that is a matter of
national debate amongst people our age
right now so here's Mitchell
pineapple belongs on Pizza it's
disgusting do you like pineapple on
pizza
I do not have pineapple on Pizza
um but we've got a rule on a Friday
um but how busy I am I'll stop work and
we'll always have a night in without it
so our boys 14 our girl is 12. and the
big discussion is because we always have
a takeaway like what are we going to
have pizza's always there our little
girl is always lobbying for pizza
um but not pineapple for me no we don't
like pineapple
sure a lot of world leaders haven't
asked that one
that's a very important question
so last one from me this is kind of like
a two-in-one question so I'm 12. if you
could go back in time until your 12 year
olds or something what would they be I
mean I know back in the days even this
has become a profitable line try out for
Arsenal good choice by the way I'm gonna
Arsenal support
so yeah I mean I've I've wanted to be a
football until I realized I wasn't good
enough I did all the usual things the 12
year old boy what you want to be
I gave one piece of advice to both of
you and to all young people
it would be believe in yourself and that
you can do it and you may think well
that's a bit of that bit of advice but
when I was your age because I came from
a working class background
I didn't think that someone like me
would be an MP I really didn't think
someone like me would lead the labor
party and I really really didn't think
someone like me would ever be prime
minister there's something in my head
saying that's not the sort of thing that
you're going to be doing here because
they think if they're not from a certain
background they can't do something but
you can achieve anything if you really
care about that's such an important
thing and it's really important that
both of you say that as well because for
other people of your age coming from you
will be far far more powerful than
coming from me so keep saying it well Mr
stamina so much for coming here on FYI
and answering all of our questions thank
you so much for having me it's been a
pleasure thank you thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you and coming
soon on FYI we'll be putting your
questions to the Prime Minister Rishi
sunak
and for more info on some of the
subjects we've been discussing with the
labor leader check out our video
experience and reports on our webpage
first.news FYI fantastic good to see you
see you next time see you next time
[Music]
a little bit